you
we are yes net look young intrapreneur
society from Hong Kong what we do it's
basically we nurture young sauce ginger
penis and we incubate early-stage young
social enterprise startups so well we
encounter design thinking two years ago
and we think it's a really amazing and
powerful framework and innovation
framework and we apply design thinking
in our social innovation so we really
thank you so much for the opportunity
for coming here and basically my name is
thousand and this is Carmen and this is
Maggie from yes now
well design thinking it we give a lot of
trainings of design thinking to empower
this you when they want to solve what
they want to create the change that I
wanted to design thinking actually
helped them from really discover know
about the social problems empathy to
defining and then problem finding and
then including the ideas come up with
the ideas and prototype it and validated
in the business model so this the whole
process really helps all the people in
the YES Network to really come up with
the solution I think the program is
really inspiring because Paris they only
three the material from preschool from
ideal but while we are really present at
here we really get these fairs and we
think like we can generate more stores
later on when we're back and like I
think that what we lack most is all the
Masters are tripping very close to us
and we gather their experience and their
advice and like the problem finding part
is really is very for us because we are
doing social we are solving social
problems so the problem our wiki problem
very complicated so that part's really
matter house yes so in my point of view
I think that this program is just very
inspiring and I just amazed by how many
exercise we do you know in the workshop
and it's the hands-on experience that
makes a difference is not you know the
material itself and how the professor
says it the lecturer says it is very
inspiring as well because they have the
knowledge and experience to really
explain not just your plain Leon worse
but their own you know and i think the
application for us could be you know to
my point of view i really like the
ideation part because i always come up
with ideas but i think they teach me the
way how i do it correctly and it's not
only by perceiving but I practice it and
i think i'm going to take back because
we need to have ideas
well basically the thing I love the most
about the master innovation series it's
just of course that bring the top
innovation gurus from around the
d.school to in the same place where you
can get close contact with and they were
so warm to give you a lot of advice and
interaction and another amazing thing in
the course itself it shows you all the
different inspiring like how they use
bio combining mount radical
collaboration between disciplines like
the bio and with the mechanical
engineering in the kinetic sand oh and
they show you in front and then and let
you do the exercise so this is what
amazing that we could bring the
application in your company that you can
see throughout the course so it's pretty
amazing
so I think this place is really amazing
and any company NGOs whatever you're
doing is always relevant because this is
a thinking style this is a thinking
philosophy and we should all think about
it creatively because we have this
creative potential and I think by
realizing it in this three days anyone
should take part and I hope that you
know any learning can be taken and to
the daily life that we can apply not
only to our companies or organizations
I'll see seize the opportunity embrace
the challenge and reach out those
amazing people in every innovation back
to your government of national
false for me I think the design thinking
could help your company move a step
forward it's like really except the
whole industry the whole innovation for
it and by learning design thinking you
will definitely reach a higher level of
your company so we welcome to come to
join this
you